pop
[Musique]
louis ferdinand céline était médecin son
roman voyage au bout de la nuit paru en
1932 est considéré comme un des
chefs-d'oeuvre de la littérature
française une vision désabusée plutôt
désespérée sur l'humanité après les
boucheries de la guerre de 14 18 patrick
pelloux est médecin
il est médecin urgentiste rappelez vous
c'est lui en août 2003 qui alerte la
france sur les dangers de la canicule
cette canicule tu feras près de 15000
morts des personnes âgées pour la
plupart patrick peloux continue son
travail de mise en garde contre les
risques sanitaires
il a publié urgentistes chez fayard
aujourd'hui et nous livre sa lecture du
roman de céline voyage au bout de la
nuit
louis ferdinand céline patrick peloux du
médecin de regard sur une humanité
souffrante qui ne sont pas si
différentes qu'on pourrait l'imaginer
mais surtout écoutez bien vous allez
entendre la voix étrange de louis
ferdinand céline
[Musique]
j'aurais pu faire mon céline avec la
canicule enfer voyage au bout du soleil
[Musique]
non j'attends trop rêche en rogne un
villa soir je te ferai dans les murs
deux ans trou noir ton âme de vaches
dans les transes peut prendre à du show
tu verras cb assistons ce tu verras peur
commente non non ce grand cimetière 10
11 ans ne sera pas facile
[Musique]
voyage au bout de la nuit ça reste à un
témoignage quasiment historique avec le
temps et ce bouquin qui est écrit juste
avant la seconde guerre finalement entre
les deux guerres ils sortent d'une
guerre ou eu un nombre de morts
incroyable et où ils vont rentrer dans
une autre ils le savent pas et ils sont
avec le même état de misère et lui il
fait ce qu'il peut et il fait tellement
ce qui peut que d'un coup y y renonce ce
qui n'a pas changé c'est l'homme
c'est-à-dire la condition humaine
ces lignes sur ce qu'il écrit on
s'aperçoit qu'il ya certains textes qui
pourraient être vraiment calqué sur les
personnes âgées à l'heure actuelle avec
la halle avec une déchéance totale avec
ddt des mouroirs est passé dans des
maisons de retraite des fois il ya un
aquarium on sait pas si c'est les
poissons qui regardent les personnes
âgées ou de création des rythmes et des
poissons pour les tenir a fait
on dit en le taxant de cadeaux communs
porteront mal fabricant ce que leur
rendement de fayoum en maintenant la
vision d'hôpital ça c'est très
intéressant comment ces vignes le décrit
parce que à l'époque l'hôpital c'était
vraiment le
enfin site c'était là le l'endroit on
mettait les pauvres c'était là où on
mettait toute la misère l'hôpital
laennec avait été construit pour mettre
les malades qui étaient issus de la
tuberculose
on y faisait rien n'y avait pas
d'antibiotiques qui avait rien donc
c'était vraiment des mouroirs en quelque
sorte
et c'était la honte d'aller à l'hôpital
ça existe encore ça ça existe encore et
les structures d'accueil notamment du
samu social
beaucoup ne veulent pas y aller l'année
dernière en période de grand froid vous
aviez jusqu'à 4000 places de libres mais
ils veulent pas y aller parce qu'il se
dit je veux pas aller dans les centres
d'hébergement parce que c'est un
roulement de pau je ne suis pas pauvre
ces trois des nouvelles que dans crocs
cote est pourri ce que dit céline ce
qu'ils disent et que en effet les il ya
beaucoup de médecins c'est des gens
d'argent lui céline il dit je vais pas
leur demander du fric parce qu'ils en
ont pas donc il est dans une danse dans
une ambiguïté comme ça donc nous on le
voit aux urgences beaucoup de pas très
cher on fait pas de priver on ne demande
pas d'argent on soigne point barre
il y en a plein qui vont voir des grands
professeurs dans la qui seront payés en
liquide du som a su côtelettes chambre
et là ils sont crédibles dans son
bouquin elle va voir ils vont voir des
gens qu'on paie grassement qui ont une
apparence donc du coup c'est sérieux
c'est comme ça qu'à tromper militants
grand peine tu vas voir ce joli compile
que je batte or l'onu recommande la fin
de bafou ya j'en exaltation on part vim
au près du lit de la jeune fille
prostrée la malade à la derni voulu
l'examiner
mais il perdait tellement de sens
c'était une telle bulle
qu'on ne pouvait rien voir de son vagin
des caillots ça faisait glouglou entre
ses jambes je remis le gros coton et
remontaient sa couverture simplement
bien ça la scène de l'avortement c'est
c'est une scène qu'on voyait encore il
ya quelques années les faiseuses d'anges
ça s'appelait c'était une véritable
boucherie
moi j'ai pas connu cette époque parce
que je suis un tout jeune docteur mais
quand on regarde dans la littérature
ça faisait plus de morts que de bien à
l'époque c'était un crime quasiment il y
avait des femmes qui finissait en prison
pour ça c'est une scène absolument
épouvantable parce que vous avez
l'hémorragie dit il décrit exactement
comme si on y était et en fait la suite
était souvent table parce qu'elle meure
[Musique]
chacun possède ses raisons pour s'évader
de sa misère intime et chacun de nous
pour y parvenir emprunte aux
circonstances
quelques ingénieux chemin heureux ceux
auxquels le bordel suffit d'en c'est
marrant parce que c'est une belle
conclusion parce que heureux ceux
auxquels le bordel suffit ça pourrait
être vraiment l'un des principes de des
services d'urgence
en fait merci parce que je vais y avait
longtemps que j'avais pas lu le voyage
au bout de la nuit mais ça m'a fait du
bien de leur classe
[Musique]